any show with the following as massive
as stranger things is going to have fans
throwing theories around and over the
last two seasons viewers have scrambled
for answers to a number of questions
some involved the mysteries of the
upside-down
others tackle Elevens origins and some
are just predictions of where future
seasons may take some fan favorite
characters plenty of these ideas are
just plain wacky however I am on a
curiosity voyage and I need my paddles
to travel so let's take a look at some
of the stranger things fan theories that
may end up being accurate daddy dearest
let's start with a fun one shall we
before we ventured into Hawkins Indiana
with stranger things there was another
small town in the Hoosier State that
boasted a big haired beau like Steve
Harrington Parks and Recreation took
place in Pawnee Indiana while that show
was entirely different
its residents silly man jean-ralphio
looks an awful lot like Steve which has
led some theorists to believe that they
may be father and son since Parks and
Rec takes place in the modern era and
stranger things has set in the 80s the
timelines match up just as well as their
hairstyles so it's definitely a workable
fan theory and the actors portraying the
characters have since played along with
the popular notion as well the only
question is who's gonna be the lucky
mrs. Harrington with whom he has young
jean-ralphio
and speaking of paternity theories
Hopper's daughter the first season
explains that chief hoppers young
daughter died years before the show
began but some have suggested that her
death might have ultimately been a
cover-up for her abduction the people
behind the Hawkins lab already proved
they could fake a death with will in
season 1 and we now have confirmation
that the children they put through the
program are abductees it seems totally
possible that hoppers daughter was one
of their experiments
perhaps number one to seven 9 or 10 on
the other hand there are also some who
believe 11 might actually be his
daughter sure she's able to sniff out
files that make her believe she's Jane
the long-lost daughter of another
telekinetic woman whose daughter was
stolen but hoppers the one who had those
files hidden in his house wouldn't it be
something if the reason he was
transferring so much protective fatherly
energy to 11 is that she actually is his
own flesh and blood
stranger things have happened career
paths there's no doubt that Steve was
the surprise MVP of season 2 what's next
for the former pretty boy bully remains
to be seen
his entire post graduation plans seem to
revolve around Nancy Wiest no longer
with he spent the whole season subbing
in as a big brother slash babysitter for
Dustin and the other kids so now some
are drawing parallel lines between his
art and that of chief hopper considering
the fact that Hopper has no one he can
trust with all this sensitive
information about the other side in his
own squad perhaps he'll recruit Steve to
join the force and become as new deputy
the only real question is whether he'd
be allowed to maintain his signature
mane while in uniform very nice dish the
upside down as far as we know the upside
down is a parallel dimension that was
accidentally open by all those
government experiments gone wrong and
now that Elevens worked her supreme
magic the gate is closed but what if
there's more to it than that we know
from the last shot for the fight against
the mine flare is far from done but what
if instead of fighting a parallel world
this is a battle against the future the
upside down is characterized by images
of a Hawkins ravaged by destruction
decay and rot perhaps instead of seeing
some second dimension what's trickling
into the scene is a dreadful sense of
inevitability that's itching to come
true now the mind flare maybe some
Terminator style time traveler who's
ready to take over the town and possibly
the world sooner rather than later new
spies season two of stranger things sees
the show's new Big Bad the mine flare
possess will buyers and turn him into
his spy we still know very little about
this monster but his possession of will
at least gave us a few answers as to how
he functions the most important tidbit
contact with him could have lingering
effects namely in regards to his ability
to spy on our world through those he's
touched given this a few fans seem to
think that he's already found his next
set of eyes while exploring the tunnels
beneath Hawkins both hopper and Dustin
discover a weird object on the wall that
shoots a strange substance onto them
they clean it off in short order and
little as set of it past that but the
duffer brothers aren't the kind of show
runners to introduce something like that
if it isn't gonna pay off later this has
led many to believe that Dustin and
hopper are now infected by the mine
flare and will perhaps act as his new
spies fast-forward the time jump between
seasons 1 and 2 of stranger things was
roughly one year but many fans posit
that the show will jump forward even
further in future seasons considering
how quickly the child stars are aging
might not be too unreasonable to expect
the series to bypass the
one year mark and take them straight
into highschool in season three if so
that put the show near the tail end of
the decade and open up a whole new
strain of cinematic callback potential
think the fly and terminator in the Lost
Boys if they wait long enough to launch
production on a third season they could
very well hop into the next decade the
90s and start throwing out homages to
sci-fi picks of that era like the abyss
and tremors in Jurassic Park
it could happen spinoff the seventh
episode of stranger things 2 is left a
lot of viewers divided over whether 11
really even needed to venture out to
Chicago to link up with her lost
institution sister collie who bears the
number 8 on her wrists but while 11 was
figuring out that her friends and
Hawkins were important enough to fight
for there's still a story to be told
through Collies mission for vengeance
sure her appearance could just be a
preview of clutch reunions to come for
all the labs other missing children but
it could also be the first attempt to
spark a spin-off for the series the
unpopularity of the episode might derail
any plans for producing a collie centric
spinoff but don't be surprised if the
duffer brothers give it another shot
with some more new characters in the
coming seasons thanks for watching click
the looper icon to subscribe to our
youtube channel plus check out all this
cool stuff we know you'll love to
[Music]